Far Cry games are defined by their
exotic settings and six is headed to the
Caribbean here's what you need to know
about the fictional island of Yarra and
it's political turmoil in the past
Ubisoft claimed its games were a
political that's not the case with far
cry 6 the island of Yarra is modeled
after Cuba and it's in bad shape due to
economic sanctions and isolationism as a
result the population is rising up
against their malevolent dictator
Presidente Antone Castillo Castillo is
played by Giancarlo Esposito who's no
stranger to portraying villains many
know him as the ruthless Gustavo Fring
from Breaking Bad and better call Saul
and you might also recognize him as the
dentist from payday 2 facing him is hero
Danny Rojas a native Yaron who teams up
with the rebel forces Danny can be
either male or female you can customize
their appearance and they will be fully
voiced in cutscenes as you take control
of Danny and explore the island you'll
come across the range of environments
we've come to expect from Far Cry
jungles beaches farms and towns but for
the first time in the series this game
actually features larger cities
including Yara's capital you can explore
all of those with allies thanks to the
returning thanks for Hire feature one of
your buddies is an absolutely adorable
little wiener dog named Teresa AI
partners and large areas to explore
aren't new to Far Cry and to be honest
neither is this political flavor but
this is the first time we've seen Far
Cry so overtly embrace the politics far
cry 6 is looking to examine concepts
like systemic oppression and revolution
if that sounds like something you're
into you can check out game spots
pre-order guide for more info Far Cry 6
will have standard gold ultimate and
collector's editions and some of the
pre-order bonuses confirm the return of
zany weapons like a disc launcher far
cry 6 releases on February 18 20 21 and
it's coming to ps4 PS 5 xbox one series
X PC & stadia
[Music]
you